all right people
i believe we are live minor technical
difficulties here
in the brand spanking new studio we're
in google live streaming
and across from me across the pond i've
got
carl benjamin aka sargon of akkad carl
how are you
very glad to uh finally have it all
working how are you doing
i'm good i have to say you're a very
patient person because
when the stream went down you're very
calm are you are you on the drugs
uh no i'm just used to google hangouts
once once we get the studio fully going
we have some like fancy tricaster stuff
that'll we won't have to do it through
hangouts so we're
we're doing the best we can in this
crazy time how do you like our sort of
uh well this is the new set and we we
faked it a little to look like there's
just some stuff going on how does that
look to you um it looks uh in progress
in progress exactly all right all right
there's a ton i want to talk to you
about
and uh you know when we did this i had
you on my show i think
a little over a year ago now uh i said
to you that when i was sort of having my
kind of awakening about what was going
on with the left and that i felt that
liberals
were no longer liberal they were
becoming illiberal and
progressives were becoming regressives
when i started tweeting about this stuff
and sort of
awakening to it everybody online on
twitter and on facebook was saying
sargon of akkad is the guy you have to
talk to this is what he's been talking
about
and all that stuff so for the people
that don't know who you are
um first just tell me a little bit about
yourself privately and then sort of
when you woke up to what you now see as
uh as a big problem on the left there
are people who don't know who i am
i'd like to meet them for the three or
four people who just got the internet
this week you know
i only say that but i've actually had
people in real life say my friend's a
really big fan of yours and i was
thinking oh my god
you know that's that's worrying isn't it
like
but um yeah it's like you just sit in a
little room and you talk and then holy
cow people are watching
i know um yeah i guess um it was about
three years ago now that well i mean it
must have been before that but i just
in the news i just kept seeing things
that were just
objectionable and normally these
objectionable things would be coming
from
the right uh but this was coming from
the left and it was
coming from people who i thought should
know better and from people who had a
great deal of influence and
and once at mainstream media like
newspapers and television outlets and
stuff like this and i'm
thinking why are they effectively
why are they doing all this why are they
going so far outside of the bounds of
what you would think
is an appropriate position you know i
mean so give me an example of something
that you saw that you were like wait a
minute wait a minute
what's happening here oh god this is
years ago now i can't
i can't even remember i can barely
remember what i saw last week
all right well okay so without giving
what you know specifics
yeah sorry forget forgetting the
specifics then give me your liberal
cred because one of the things that i
see pop up sometimes is that for those
of us that are on the left
that that criticize the left and as i
say all the time there's a zillion of us
that criticize the right
i criticize the right too but yes i
focus on the left because i want my team
to be better
can you give me some of your liberal
credentials so that people will say
people will go oh he actually is a
liberal or a classical liberal
what do you even consider yourself i
really i do consider myself to be a
classical liberal
um i am very concerned that
all people be treated the same within
the under the in the eyes of the law
that that's one thing that really
concerns me um i mean
liberalism springs from individual
rights and the very idea of group rights
is it's just
the complete opposite of what they're
trying to achieve in fact that was the
thing that
liberalism was really trying to defeat
the whole
if you have a system of universal rights
and then you give a certain group a
certain number of rights
that the other people don't have a not
only is that obviously by default not
universal
but b it creates a group of people
who have different rules to the rest of
you how is that any different to an
aristocracy
that's my you know i just i just can't
get over that that is the the
fundamental point
of why i dislike group rights and any
liberal should be against group rights
whereas progressives seem remarkably in
favor of group rights and
i'm just in awe that they don't seem to
understand that that's an
anti-liberal position to hold you know
when they say okay we want this for
black people who want this for women you
know quotas or
anything of the sort it's like no you
know we we're all
equals we're all going to be treated as
equals under the law and we're going to
have
that we're not no special favors because
under what in what world does being
black or a woman
or any other kind of minority category
inform you really about that
person you can't ever say well yeah well
he's black
therefore and they're a woman therefore
you know you can never tell anything
about anyone's kind of personality or
anything like that
or the character or their achievements
or their you know anything
and so it just really drives me crazy
when i i i guess it was
i mean looking back i guess it was the
increasing encroachment of identity
politics
into the left and not even encroachment
just the sort of steamrolling of the
left
from identity politics it's been
infuriating because it
it's inherently chauvinistic it drives
me crazy it's like okay so
i mean if we take it like an example
like um violence against women you think
oh my god
domestic violence against women that's
awful and then you look at the
statistics
40 of domestic violence is against men
so if you're gonna say right okay we're
concerned with violence against women
you are
implicitly saying you're not caring
about violence against men
and it's not even the fact that violence
is going on that's really the problem
it's the fact that women are suffering
as a group rather than
individuals whoever's suffering from
violence because everyone suffers from
violence you know when
when someone has something done to them
they suffer you know there's
i don't think we should really even be
considering who suffers more
you know we've got systems in place that
say right okay you don't abuse each
other
if someone's been the recipient of abuse
why does it matter
what their characteristics are so
right so basically as as a classical
liberal you believe in
individual liberty you believe in uh
the individual versus the collective you
want everyone to be treated equally now
i
try my best and i probably fail at this
all the time
but i try not to impugn the motivations
of the progressives now obviously i
think the progressives have lost their
mind
hence they've gone from progressive to
regressive um
but do you believe that they knowingly
are doing something bad like
it's hard to say and i know that goes
from you know you've got the leaders of
the movement first the average
you know a lot of these ideas sound good
to kids which is why socialism
suddenly sounds good to kids even though
we know it's never
done any good anywhere but what do you
think about the motivations of these
people because a lot of them you know
they say well
we want uh minorities to be treated
equal so we should have quotas now i get
why
that doesn't really work in reality of
course but but that concept
well one of okay just a uh we want
minorities to be treated
equally then quotas i mean that's not an
equal treatment unless you're going to
have a quota of white people they
they have this in the british
broadcasting corporation in britain
right
where they they will literally advertise
jobs and say
uh this is open to non-whites um they
call them
black asian or minority ethnic
in britain uh but basically they just
mean non-white and
and it's not i mean if it was for say
like um
a television program or something that
was a period piece or something like
that say in
africa or something i would say of
course you're not gonna have like you
know
white people in pre-colonial africa but
when it's for like a research position
like an 18 grand a year research
position
why on earth can you justify saying well
you know what we just don't want white
people for that
and it's just crazy so that's you can't
do that um what was the first part of
the question again sorry
well that do you think they all sort of
know this like oh right
like we know that it's bad we know that
it's obviously bad and that's why i'm
always
for the individual i would be for what
martin luther king said don't judge
someone
by the color of their skin but by the
content of their character but do you
think that all of the people that we're
railing against all the time
do you think they fully get it no no
this it is a lot like socialism as you
say it
a lot of it sounds good on paper and
this
draws a lot of people in because it's
always pitched as a moral
attitude this is this is the good thing
to do
and you know being for individual
liberty is
i i'm going to say a bad thing because
they never frame it in those terms
because i don't think they really think
deep enough to
categorize it like that but well they
tell you you're selfish right if you're
for individualism it somehow sounds
selfish even though
i would i would argue that you should do
what is good for you and then you might
do also what's good for your family and
your extended community
and your your local community and all
that it's actually more simple than that
if you're arguing for group rights
you're arguing for rights that i don't
get to have
i can't imagine anything more selfish
than that i'm arguing for rights
everyone has
there's there's nothing more altruistic
than that as far as i can think of
you know it's just by definition i can't
that can't be the selfish position if
you're saying that you know
other people must have something i can't
have that's terrible it's absolutely
terrible
but some no i i don't i don't think
they're all bad people or anything
in fact
the majority of people are well-meaning
with without a doubt
you know they the these are the people
who they they log on they watch uh
certain online news venues and they
they think yeah okay yeah i agree of
course and uh right
and then they they just carry on with
their day and they they don't really
think about it
but there are definitely people who are
i don't know what you call them thought
leaders or something like that
uh who i mean there are definitely
certain individuals who
are doing what they're doing willfully
and they're pushing things
for specific agendas i mean there are
some people i mean
guardian author jessica valenti is is
just she's just
i mean she can't possibly think that
she's doing something altruistically and
if she does
that just speaks more to her mental
state than anything i mean
she actually in an article she actually
called just outright
for men to be paid less money than women
on the basis that their men as a
solution to closing the
wage gap in the article she got informed
by a lawyer that that would in fact be
illegal
because we have laws to say that you
can't pay people differently based on
their gender and all she was like well
bummer
i mean that they were her literal words
in the ass but it's like this person's a
lunatic
why why is she why does she have a job
at the guardian
i i mean i don't wrong that that's
actually the wrong question to ask
of course she has of course yeah yeah
yeah come on now uh yeah
yeah yeah but you see i i come from a
time when i
you know from the 90s when the guardian
was respectable paper and they didn't
push this sort to the
level they do now but you know what are
you gonna do um but yeah so that i i
i don't know necessarily but there are
definitely certain individuals who are
using
social justice advocacy and sort of the
extreme progressivism
as a cover for their own bad actions
because this is
this is what drives me crazy about it
the most is it's it's
so collectivist it's lost sight of the
individual
um look at their definition of racism
for example right so
if they say that racism isn't just
prejudice based on race which is
the definition everyone else uses you
know you're being prejudiced for this
person why because he's black
that's racism well if they then redefine
racism to mean
systemic oppression or prejudice based
on race or oppression whichever they
want to use
then an individual can never be accused
of being racist
because that individual is not the
organization i mean at best you could
say a representative of an organization
could be a racist
because he represents that organization
in an official capacity
but otherwise it just doesn't make sense
and then mathematics is terrible as well
i mean i
i'm terrible at maths as well but even i
know that if you have
if racism is power plus prejudice if
power is zero
it's just racism is prejudice right
from a mathematics point of view even i
know this you know if they if they had
any brains but between them
they've gone racism is power times
prejudice
so is that is that the issue though is
that the issue that it really in a way
it's sort of a brain power issue
because if you were to think a lot of
this stuff through if you were to think
what being a human is all about how
government should treat us how we should
treat our
neighbor and all of that none of it
really makes sense but it just kind of
sounds good which goes to you know
someone like ben shapiro always says
you know it's feelings over facts right
and that it all
kind of feels good and i know even in my
personal life now even though most
people know my
opinions on things when i when i'll meet
someone new and i'll talk about some
stuff and they're
they they feel a lot of this [ __ ]
when i start talking to them about it i
can see it's like in a personal affront
it doesn't become a political
conversation it's as if i'm
just attacking the person and that's a
really dangerous
place to be right yeah i mean this this
disregard for the individual
is it permeates the whole ideology and i
mean i read
an article today in fact where the there
was a woman talking about how
her ex-boyfriend had gone to a black
lives matter protest
after dedicating himself to being a
full-time social justice activist
and he had been uh i don't know man
handled by the cops
and they pushed him onto the floor and
she and i swear she wrote this
she said i wasn't worried for his safety
because the cops usually
something that killed more black people
more often than white people
and so she didn't have a fear for her
safety and so yeah but what if that is a
psychotic cop
and he's really pissed off with that guy
and he just pulls out his gun and shoots
him
and you'd be like well i mean they don't
usually do that it wouldn't change
anything the guy's still
dead right and they and they also shoot
plenty of white people too yeah well
they
per capita they shoot more white people
than black people
in total in aggregate they they keep
more open by people it's just
per capita it's disproportionately black
but um
i imagine there's probably something to
crime rates
crazy right um yeah all right so
this isn't to exonerate the police
though either because the u.s police
definitely have
um that in in certain departments are
definitely overbearing and authoritarian
there's no doubt about it i mean i
wouldn't want to get into a tussle with
the la cops
you know i i would be very respectful
and do exactly what they said when they
said it just because
but just to condemn police in general
and again
they it's it's collective blame and in
collective guilt and individual blame
they want to
you know they if something happens with
them like with black lives matter and
trevor noah
tommy uh lara the other day that
interview in infuriated me
i i was literally i mean i got to the
point where i was just what
i wanted to ask what does black lives
matter have to do
for you to stop supporting them trevor
you know they've murdered cops they
chant for cop dead cops all the time
they they riot they loot they burn they
beat people based on the you know
they're members who beat people on the
racial
uh racial status so i mean what has to
happen for him to go okay maybe this has
gone too far
but he just wants to you know whimsies
away going well that's just those people
but the grand narrative of black lives
matter isn't about that it's like well
it doesn't matter does it
well it's almost like you're kind of
caught at that point in
your collectivist bubble right you're
caught
between well we're doing something
that's collectivist
now we've got some bad apples here but
we don't want to be judged
as a collective but yeah
oh absolutely but the second a white man
does something
then it's all white men if you're a
white man you're oppressing women you're
replacing black people you're pressing
gays
you you are doing all of this stuff even
if you as an individual aren't doing it
because they are interested in the group
and not the individual and it's like
look
you want to have your cake and eat it
too you can either have i am responsible
and then
in turn black lives matter is
responsible for the crimes members of
black lives matter commit
or those individuals are responsible for
that and
i as an individual are responsible for i
do and
you know that i'm responsible for my
slaves okay
but um okay okay yeah yeah so it's it's
just
yeah it's just one of these things where
it's intellectual laziness
is really what i think it is and it just
becomes i mean there's a there's a
parody series on youtube called uh
regressives and the tagline is think
regressive
i can't remember it's easier or
something it's just easier and it really
is it's a lot easier to say
well this is white people's fault or
this is men's fault or this is you know
who i'm
saying that that doesn't answer anything
and that that's not actionable in any
way what do you
i mean what do you think we're going to
do stop well as jessica valenti wanted
just
demoting men's pay you know garnishing
men's pay
on the basis that they're men are you
it's the most illiberal thing i can
imagine and it's
kind of this kind of desire for forced
equality i find
baffling because in a free society
the last thing you'd expect to see is
sort of a perfect equality of anything
anywhere you'd expect to see lots of
individual people
all progressing through this society at
different rates because they've got
different interests different abilities
they come from different backgrounds
they want to do different things you
would never
expect to see like 50 men 50 women as
ceos
i mean why why would that happen i mean
these people have taken different
they've made different life choices to
arrive at the position that they're at
there is absolutely no rational reason
to expect it to be 50 50
and i'm still waiting for the
justification to make it 50 50.
why should that happen i mean why why
for diversity well that's not good
enough reason i'm afraid especially not
to
there was an australian uh ceo she was a
woman and she was i wasn't the ceo was
it the press we were reporting on
i can't remember exactly who it was but
it was an australian article i saw and
the
i'm sure was a ceo that was being
interviewed and the women literally said
well yes some men are going to have to
lose their jobs for diversity i know
there we go that's exactly that's
exactly my point these these people who
have worked their whole lives they've
done nothing wrong
and they've obviously earned everything
they've got are about to lose it
on the basis that they were born wrong
and i i can't countenance that i'm sorry
that's that's unacceptable
and it has to stop you know i've heard a
parallel on that which
is that you'll hear and i think oprah
said this once
we're talking talking about racists uh
that you know you just
we just need this older generation to
die and i remember thinking and you hear
this idea a lot you know that older
americans are more racist so we just
need them to die
and it's like that that's such a
dangerous endgame of why progressivism
will eventually eat itself
because you always need a new oppression
so one day even if you've lived your
whole life
as the most progressive person ever
there may be something that comes down
the pike 30 years from now
that you're like you know what i don't
think uh people should have sex with
robots
while in pools you know but the
progressives want and now they're gonna
want you dead too
not that i would problem with robot
water sex but
you know but that's the problem that it
just will eat itself
and it's like yeah that that's because
it's a purity test the whole damn thing
is a purity test
and i i've i feel sorry for those
sort of um the the whites progressive
college professors
who and i again this is another thing
that i've seen um
a woman a professor who's saying that
she can't have kids
because if she has kids they'll be white
and she'll be contributing to racism
because of course all white people are
racist because
you live in royal in the white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy
where all white people are uh privileged
and oppressed are by virtue of that
oppressing
non-white people and it's like okay and
then but
i love on the same hand that they're
like yeah and so you know i'm actually
really pro-immigration so why
why would you want to bring non-white
people into an oppressive
white society that's the worst thing you
can do for them that is the least
humanitarian thing
if you're a progressive it's incredible
there is no internal consistency in
their ideology
it's funny i was speaking i was speaking
at a high school a couple weeks ago
and they had you know a libertarian and
a liberal and an anarchist
and a socialist bubble and the socialist
white guy
kept going on and on about the evil male
patriarchy and white men and for white
men have pillaged this
and white men have destroyed that and i
literally turned to him on the thing and
i said you know you're white
so it's like the just the the lack of
self-awareness even
is just crazy but but quick segue here
uh because i know we could do this for
the for the full hour
um is what makes for all of the things
that you've said i think a lot of people
would listen to everything you've said
say okay that all kind of makes sense
but actually carl and probably dave too
they're libertarians
what makes you not a libertarian uh and
more of a classical liberal
right okay now this this is um oh god
this is getting into
territory i didn't think we were going
to go into um that's what i asked
i'm not against the concept of
government now i understand that
libertarians are
i i think they're there for uh limited
government
small government and on by that
definition
to me that just sounds like common sense
why waste money on something that you
don't need
if you don't need to have a a giant
monolithic government entity why why
have it you know why pay for it
um but i often find that libertarians
tend to go
far too far with that for example they
they you know in america they seem to be
very much against um
social health care and the welfare state
and they're they're
done wrong there are definitive problems
with the welfare state and
the rest of the world the modern world
is looking at you thinking you don't
have universal healthcare
everyone else does and we're getting
along okay um
but i mean i hear your healthcare is
really good quality so there's there's
that but
i i just i always i always hear stories
of people getting sick and then going
bankrupt from getting sick and i think
that is the least humanitarian thing
ever um i
i was actually going to bring this up a
bit later on in actually but since we're
at it um
let's let's talk about now yeah so the i
think the difference
comes from the fundamental definition of
freedom
that i have and i think that differs
from libertarians because
libertarians they very focused on
government and i don't blame them
because the us government is a
giant almost out of control monster
when it when you look at like the things
the us government is doing around the
world and
that's not even the worst it could be
doing it's actually surprisingly
restrained for such
a giant beast but it is doing terrible
things and it has in the past
done terrible things and so i can
understand and especially the sort of
disconnect between the people and the
government these days
and i mean that was honestly part of the
fun of watching trump's campaign
was watching all of the powers that be
aligned behind
hillary clinton and then watching her
lose that was
i mean she spent more 1.4 billion on her
campaign
you know with like you know all of the
you know wall street the the all the
banks
almost all the politicians almost all
the press
any all the all the academics anyone who
thought they were anyone
we're all like well hey you've all got
to get behind hillary she's definitely
going to win trump has no chance
you know anyone who says any otherwise
is is insane
and then trump wins and we see this just
total catastrophic collapse of
their own worldview i mean what can they
say to justify any of this well
i mean we we didn't mean it
you know right um so um yeah so
sorry i'm getting off topic so basically
my
my issue is the definition of freedom so
i agree
that being being wary of a giant
government power
is definitely something that anyone with
any kind of like
liberty minded uh frame of mind should
be concerned about
obviously you know government is a dire
source of power um
but that's not the only thing that can
prevent a person from being free
and the liberty libertarians seem to
define freedom as just freedom from
government interference
whereas if you if you look at if you
look at liberalism
is in historically i mean it wasn't
necessarily afraid of government it was
afraid of tyranny
and there was there's definitely forms
of tyranny that come
from without the government i mean the
sjws are the perfect example they they
are social tyrants
and they will i mean it's really in it's
really heartening to see the number of
professors there's only it's only about
a handful it's unlike five or six
who have come out and in direct
opposition to social justice like jordan
peterson gadsad
and a few others and christine half
summers who are who are stridently
anti-social justice
almost universally on the fact that it's
illiberal
and that sort of chilling effect i think
it has kept a lot of people quiet
but um and that that isn't that's in
itself
a form of control it's a form of
oppression and it doesn't come from the
government
and so this is what i think libertarians
need to understand like for example
poverty is
a man who has no house who has no food
who has no
having water he can't shower he can't
wash he can't
he can't dress himself properly that's
not a free man
even though the government isn't going
to be keeping him you know
their thumb on his he's not paying any
tax but he's not a free man
he can't do anything i mean who's going
to employ this person where's he going
to sleep he's just
this is not freedom this is just slavery
to poverty and so
one of the things about classical
liberalism is it's not necessarily
against
helping the poor i mean i've got
i've got my copy of the road surf them
here and i'm looking forward to the
libertarians explaining to me
page 124 125 which i happen to have
bookmarked not specifically for this
interview
but just because i've had this argument
a few times where he literally says well
there's nothing wrong with having
a safety net there's nothing wrong with
social health care these these things
are not
in violation of anyone's individual
rights because they protect everyone in
the society
so there's nothing wrong with that and
one of the things i think that people on
the left have forgotten and this is why
i think so many of them think right wing
when they think classical liberal
is they've they've listened to
libertarians who said look we just don't
want any interference at all they say
okay well
i appreciate that that's what you want
but it's not what you're going to get
because the second you get that is the
second you get a communist revolution or
something like that
because the people who need help not you
know good good for libertarians being
you know upwardly mobile intelligent
active earning you know that they are
all really positive qualities
good for you mo well not most but a lot
of people in society
aren't like that and i think there's
mark carney the i think it's the
governor of bank of england
came out yesterday and said look we've
got to stop paying more attention to
what's happening to the poorest in
society
because they're getting restless they're
there their lot is getting too bad
and he's right you know it's about it's
purely about self-interest to be honest
because if you're not providing them
with any alternative you're just saying
well you know what
screw yourselves not our problem then
there is nothing nothing at all
preventing
some kind of populist from coming along
and saying hey i'll sort your problems
out just vote for me
and i think we've discovered in the past
year that they will do that
on mass to the point where everyone's
like oh my god i can't believe this is
happening
yeah and that's well that's why i don't
like to say i told you so but this is
exactly what i've spent the last two
years talking about and
you know when it comes to immigration
and islam and a whole bunch of other
stuff and all this trigger warning and
safe space stuff and people would say to
me
you know dave you're blowing this out of
proportion who cares if these college
kids
don't want this or that or whatever and
it's like no
actually there is something happening to
our society
people are afraid to say what they think
and when they're afraid to say what they
think guess what
it's very easy for a populist or a
demagogue or whatever else to come in
and give them
some easy answers so that actually makes
me want to back up to trump for a second
because i think you and i were kind of
you and i were kind of in the same thing
with trump which was that
i was thoroughly enjoying seeing
the the elite and the media and all of
these [ __ ] artists
and these talking heads that just talk
and don't have anything really to say
paid a huge amount
yeah they all get paid a ton of money of
course far more than we're making on
youtube i assure you
yeah um but all of the but all of the
power all of the money all of this stuff
they lost and the night of the election
i was on with andrew clavin i'm not sure
if you know him but he says
yeah he's a really funny guy great guy
he's a great guy
yeah and he's and he's a hardcore
conservative i just had him on the show
a couple weeks ago but he said something
that i thought was just spectacular that
night
he said look all of the elites all the
power all the money all the media all
everybody wanted
hillary to win trump won and what that
shows you
is that the power of the people in this
country is still
so powerful that it's it's the most
important thing that we have that
everyone worldwide
pretty much in every country in the
world would be jealous of what we have
and and here it is we have it so so my
question for you really
is that you saw this coming to and i saw
you were getting a lot of [ __ ] people
were saying
you're supporting trump i didn't think
it was going to happen i like
like with brexit i thought it would be
close i thought it'd be i thought it'd
be the narrowest of narrow margins
you know and i i thought that it would
be a good
a good sort of smack to the face and
give them a wake-up call and say okay
right
we've got to start thinking about
changing but i mean this is actually
better because now they've lost
so now they have no choice but to have
some sort of introspection but sorry
what was your
i interrupted you well no no i'll go
from there do you think they're having
introspection because i don't sense it i
there were a couple days where i thought
maybe they were going to and i saw a
piece in the new york times
saying the liberals have to rethink
themselves in something in new york
magazine
so a couple of the the elite elites said
yeah we have to think about it but on
the ground and in terms of the usual
cast of characters
that are leading this thing i don't see
any introspection i see doubling down on
racism and bigotry
i see doubling down on silencing people
and screaming over everybody
are you seeing it maybe you're seeing it
and i'm not oh
it is everywhere it absolutely is
everywhere and the the more sort of
radical leftist um
i don't want to call the journalists i'm
just going to call them bloggers uh
and i'm going to call them bloggers
because most of their most their
journalism
comes from twitter i'm so tired of
donald trump's twitter account
being news yeah don't you get off your
fat asses anymore and
actually going to investigate oh but
it's a lot easier to get your phone
yeah way easier um sorry i just got
straight what's the question again no
well they don't even give you a chance
they don't even give you a chance to be
outraged anymore because they're sitting
there
monitoring his twitter feed so that they
can get outraged and tell you that
you're outraged
yeah but no you're right there has been
an awful lot of doubling down when
bernie sanders came out against identity
politics that was an important thing and
i think that
a lot of bernie supporters didn't know
how to take that
and that i think spun was it the
atlantic and the new york times that
wrote pieces
that criticized identity politics saying
we're going to have to move beyond this
i think they both have new york
magazines yeah
yeah they've identified the problem but
the you're right the backlash is
terrible i mean i've i've seen
and again these are mainstream media
articles and like you know the guardian
the independent
places like this where they are just
ridiculing the concept saying that
this is this is like um the eternal howl
of the white man or something like this
it's just like
you're [ __ ] idiots you don't even
understand you know it's the fact that
you
constantly play this game of divide and
conquer
and it's just you've lost you know
you've just you've conquered a tiny
irrelevant area of the internet and
people aren't paying attention to if you
look at the numbers across the board
they're just sliding down everyone's
getting sick of their crap
and yet you know our numbers just keep
going up and they won't listen
they just won't listen so that's a
that's a perfect segue for what i think
the meat of what we can talk about here
is in case we haven't got to the meet
yet which is
that we're online media people you know
i i don't know
i don't really consider myself a
journalist in that i'm not out in the
field doing journalism i
talk i talk to people i interview people
i share my thoughts on things whatever
you want to call that that's fine
but i think one of the things that
really the narrative that really
got constructed over the course of this
election is that we know that mainstream
media has been crumbling forever they're
purging their numbers
nobody trusts them anymore they've all
gone partisan blah blah blah
and the online people that have been
doing this for a few years our numbers
are all going up people are paying
attention to us more they trust us
more all that stuff and i think it got
to perfect parity
and now we're starting to win and i'm
curious
i'm curious do you think that they are
gonna
come down on us and this can also sort
of segue into some of this youtube
censorship stuff and what's going on on
twitter
and the rest of it i mean they have a
lot of money and a lot of power still
and you know we're on a webcam and
google hangout at the moment
um so where do you think that all falls
out uh
oh god who knows um i think they will do
i mean
we are when when you attack a man's
livelihood and this the source of his
income then he's going to do everything
he can to protect that and
not you know when i say amen anyone um
they will do everything that you only
meant men i know what you meant
you meant white heterosexual gender men
that's
not even black men not not asian men
just the white men um no
so yeah they they will do everything in
their power but thankfully their power
is actually quite limited
they they don't have control over
youtube for example i mean like
if i if i do a video and use um a few
clips from say the guardian or
i actually did that that one um
regarding trevor noah with viacom i got
a copyright strike on it immediately
and i won it within a day or two youtube
came down on my side saying no this is
fair use and he can do this
and bully for you viacom um so you know
it's
youtube it's under pressure from these
sort of
activists but it's not it's not as bad
as people think
it's just it could be as bad as people
think
um and i'm not saying that it won't
become bad in the future it might
but at the moment it's not that bad it's
just that there are kind of
storm clouds on the horizon but i don't
think they i don't think it's the
mainstream media that really have the
power to do this
anymore it was honestly i think the
the i think when like historians look
back at this they'll look back and it'll
be
what was it was the new york times who
issued the
apology that they had become
cheerleaders and not journalists and
they were rededicating themselves to
honest reporting
by doing so implicitly saying that
everything they'd done before was
dishonest and it's just like i mean i
appreciate the sentiment
but you understand how awful it seems
that you have to do that
you know and and i guess it's
power had gone to their head or
something or you know ideological
conformity had gone to their head and
i don't but it's kind of a beautiful
thing don't you don't you think it's a
beautiful thing sort of
watching it watching it crumble and also
that
that all of these people it's like they
have all these all the cable news people
and all of the big media company but
they have all this money all these
resources and it's like
people don't care anymore you had your
chance
and you screwed up you know and by no
means am i saying that i'm perfect or
that you're perfect
and and by the way the the whole idea of
online media it raises a whole other set
of problems
because anyone can do this so the bar of
entry is so low
so so how do you figure out who you
trust because i'm really struggling with
that and people ask me that all the time
and it's like even when i'm reading
articles i'm like man i gotta read five
articles about the same thing just to
piece them together to figure out what
might actually have happened
that's actually what i do to its credit
that one the the one thing that the
mainstream media is actually
good at is reporting facts
if they want to um
that's a backhanded compliment if i ever
heard one isn't it just because
the the greatest the greatest crime of
the mainstream media is lies by a
mission everyone knows it everyone knows
if you go to the guardian you're gonna
get half the story if you go to the
daily mail or whatever right
fox news you're gonna get half the story
you to get a more comprehensive view you
actually do
have to like say read five articles from
different sources
to make sure that you know that and you
will find there are specific
not necessarily um not necessarily
i don't know i don't want to call them
open lies because i don't
i don't even know if these people know
that they're doing what they're doing
because i think a lot of these people
are so partisan by this point
that they don't really understand what
they're doing is dishonest i think
they just think that well you know i
mean like the number of times i hear
something go well
that's that's right wing or they'll say
or they're just doing it for money it's
like okay
they aren't refutations they're
delegitimizing tactics
you know if if you can tell me how it's
wrong then i'm all is
but if you're just going to go well i
don't like it because of the source then
you've not disproven anything and i'm
going to treat it as valid until you can
you know especially if i can't find any
obviously so yeah it's it's tough and
it's get it's gonna get more difficult
especially as
the oh my god the fake news thing really
drives me crazy
um the the irony is is quite delicious i
have to say
and the the problem is they they have a
point there is a lot going around on the
internet
that is just flat out nonsense and it
gets
you know often millions of views and
people share it people think it's true
and it's one of those things where
you've just got to be discerning you
just have to understand the landscape
and what is likely to happen from the
context of what has already previously
happened
and who is reporting what's to you uh
most people aren't that informed most
people just don't have the time to be
that informed i mean they've got jobs
they've got families that livestream
with they they expect to read a
newspaper and
even if they don't even if they don't
say look we're gonna
we're gonna give you know equal time to
you know like the the alt right as we do
to the sjws
you would at least expect some sort of
distance from one's own
biases and emotions when they're writing
the piece but unfortunately
that's just something they don't do and
so you have to
go out of your way and it's rare that i
tell my favorite articles are the ones
that are actually written
from an objective standpoint where and
at the end i don't even mind if they say
well yeah
and we think that this or i think this
or whatever but just give me the facts
without trying to put a spin on it for
the love of god
well it's just incredible to me that the
[ __ ]
news that we've all been calling out is
now calling everything else fake news
and when i say that i fully acknowledge
that your your point stands which is
that there is a lot of
there's a lot of nonsense out there in
fakery but just to show you how there is
something going on here that's kind of
bigger than us
like doesn't it seem pretty obvious to
you that there was somehow i don't know
who it was from and i'm not a conspiracy
theorist so i would always say
extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence as carl
sagan said but sorry
fans
the pizzagate thing people keep asking
me why i don't talk about it because
there's no evidence
you know every everything you're seeing
is conjecture and doing them wrong
i would never let joe biden near any of
my children you know
there are some some of those videos with
i didn't in the kids are really gross
it's disgusting isn't it it's i mean
just what does he think he's
doing but anyway sorry kevin well but
but your point
on pizzagate actually stands because i i
feel the same way a lot of people keep
tweeting it at me saying why aren't you
talking about this and it's like i can't
even
garner the slightest bit of what's
really happening here so i'll wait and
if something
is proven then of course i'll i'll talk
about it um but my
my point was that this meme of fake news
now that all the mainstream media is
saying that everything is fake
shows me that somehow there's some
coordination
somewhere i don't know what that means
exactly i'm not saying it's
a guy's at a table but there's got to be
something
and that's actually the most worrying
part right is i think that it's actually
um so in gamergate when gaming it was
happening
what we saw from the media was something
that they called a cascade effect
and it it's a good term because i think
it makes a lot of sense so basically a
thought leader in their community
someone who
you know everyone else tends to follow
would put out an article
and then i mean you know a lot of their
columns now like five paragraphs long
so take half an hour to knock this up
that basically says the same thing
and then you slap it up on your own
website and then everyone's oh god
that's a good point
right and then it just propagates it
doesn't need to have
any kind of organization because they're
all basically taking cues from one
another and going
okay oh yep yep okay we're all on the
same team great because that is how they
operate i mean we saw like with um
ezra klein's journal list they they do
operate as a faction
you know these outlets are meant to be
in competition with each other and yet
they're conspiring together
and they they they actually do it like
with malice intent malicious intent as
well so
it's just one of those things where it's
just like okay i mean
and this isn't just like nonsense we can
name the people on the list we have it
all
you know it was all leaked and it's and
the same with the uh the emails from
hillary clinton
you know the these things they they do
actually happen the the
and i tell you what i've got some advice
for conspiracy theorists because i i
i love a good conspiracy i love
conspiracies
but you you if you can't name the they
you can't report as fact you don't know
it's true
if you can't name them by name it's
nonsense
and so that's the that's the important
thing so like john podesta
tony podesta you know biden over if
there's any hard evidence connecting
them then yeah that's something
but to say like you know the new world
order wants to poison the fish and turn
the frogs gay or something
that's nonsense you know that they who
you know it's
it's too it's too broad it's too
nonsense it doesn't mean anything well i
like i like sort of the the
direction there because you're basically
saying that it's the group think that's
doing it's not a group of thinkers
it's not a group of thinkers but it's
actually group think they all taking
these cues from each other
and and going with this stuff so look
we're we're starting to win
which i think is nice but but this now
will bring us back to where we started
and it combines both of these things the
fight that you and i are trying to do
here and
really save the left if if it can be
saved do you
think do you think that we really can
win because i'll go depressing for just
a second and then i'll let you answer
is that my my fear at this point is this
thing has gotten so out of control
and now because of trump because of what
they
what they view him to be whether he is
or not but he's such a good bad guy for
them
that there's almost nothing that we can
say within the rational
part of their brain that's going to work
so for example if i say to them well you
know what
you guys were really against money in
politics hillary had all the money
trump won so that's good trump isn't a
christian conservative everyone knows he
doesn't care about gay marriage and
weed and and and abortion yes you know
like the republicans that one of the
things they hammer about is he's not a
real conservative it's like yes i know
everyone knows he's he's donald trump
he's not really
you know i i i don't think donald trump
cares about a lot of the things that
both sides care about i
really think he doesn't care at all so
what do you what do you think about the
idea that so i've been pushing this idea
or at least talking about this idea that
i think as a populist of course there's
danger with the populace hitler was a
populist so of course there's danger
but that with someone like him he's not
an ideologue in that he's not mike pence
who's
you know would take his christian
conservative views to
to govern with that we might as a
population we might be able to push him
to do some good stuff
if we can kind of agree on what good
stuff is because he wants to be liked
do you think that's a fair uh point i i
made exactly this point when i
i did an interview for a channel called
none of the above and i made that exact
point
is that donald trump he is either even
if it's even if he's
because he's a narcissist i mean he
wants to hear you
saying trump trump trump so just tell
him what you want
you know make it obvious to him you know
mass tweet at him
he obviously pays attention to what goes
on on twitter so if he gets 10 000
tweets in an hour of people going
you know don't sign the tpp or whatever
the issue is and
he's already killed that hasn't he's
already killed the tpp he's already
saved a bunch of jobs
everyone's complaining about him like
anything but he's actually got quite a
lot done
before he's even assumed the office so
he might not be that bad
he might just have been i don't know
playing the crowd or something
with regards to the left though um the
social justice warriors themselves the
the ideologue activists
who are doing this because they think it
makes them good people
will never change their mind we will
never change their mind they they will
they will they're totally indoctrinated
into this ideology and they won't change
and they don't want to
um they and the it's this is
this is one that the whole world view is
basically unfalsifiable because
if you say right okay well i i have um i
have a suggestion
they'll say yes but you're a white man
you would say that and that
just defuses everything you can ever say
it's like okay well i i guess it is
coming from a white man you know and if
that is
enough to delegitimize me then i mean we
literally have nothing to say to each
other
and thankfully that's a very unpopular
position with well both
any race really any gender most people
aren't on board with this
so this is why they lost but when it
comes to reforming the left we have to
we have to make these people understand
that they are the fundamentalist
christians they are the flat earthers of
the left
these people have lost they have lost
badly they have they held the reigns of
power for about eight years under barack
obama
and look how it's ended you've got
brexit you've got trump
le pen's coming up italy just lost their
bloody referendum
i haven't even looked into yet but
merkel just merkel just banned the burqa
today i mean
yeah merkel's arguing for banning the
bucket so look whatever you're
whatever you think about your own
ideology it's a
practical failure it hasn't worked it's
turned people against you
and now you are the most hated people in
society
you know people hate you more than they
hate the fundamentalist christians and
they used to hate the fundamentalist
christians
and so you in the marketplace of ideas
your your ideas were deemed
wanting and they have failed so if they
ever come to you and say well this is
right i don't care what you say
you're wrong to argue that position we
know that position has been discredited
it's it's absolutely nonsense so what
needs to happen is
a root and branch ideological reform on
the left where people have to get back
to the fundamental principles
and why that they're on the left what is
it they think they're advocating for
because
i mean like the the i saw this the other
day
20 uh 25 of homeless people are women in
the papers
isn't that a good thing isn't that like
hardly any of them are women but no no
that was the problem
okay what do we need to do we need to
solve solve the homeless women problem
okay
so 75 of the homeless are okay that's an
acceptable number
it's just the 25. this is the problem
with identity politics there
there is no benefit to being a man when
you're homeless
you know very very marginal benefit if
anything
and being homeless is a much heavier
burden for you know anyone to bet
to bear so we the fact that they're
women it doesn't matter
the fact that we the fact that homeless
is the problem so we need to start focus
we need to basically transition from
identity politics to issue politics so
what's the problem right homelessness
right does it matter who's homeless no
it doesn't it matters that anyone's
homeless so what do we need to do right
we need to
get whatever shelters get housing
programs get them off the streets
get them in some sort of rehabilitation
schemes get them to become productive
members of society again which i'm sure
they want as well
you know i'm sure that i i i speak to
homeless people sometimes because i i
actually
i never give to charity i don't trust
any of these big charities
but i do give change to homeless people
when i pass it on the streets because i
always look at that guy and think
if that were me my god i would just love
it if someone gave me a bit of change
and
what i really hate the sort of nefarious
or myth of oh they're just spent on
drugs
okay the dude's homeless i i if i had
some drugs i'd give them to him myself
you know this dude lives on the street
and begs for food
and you're worried about like oh he
might spend it i don't care
you know and and so i like to see when
the money's going i like to know that
someone who actually needs it is getting
it
i i'm not i would never ever recommend
giving money to like the clinton
foundation
well by the way by the way the clinton
foundation last i saw i think about a
week ago their their donations were down
something around 40 percent
which just proves what the point was the
whole time
they were doing such great work and all
of their people all of their donors were
doing it just because it was so great
well then of course you'd keep giving
the donations but it wasn't about that
it was about access
and now that she will have less
influence you will get less access
it's like it all all of the stuff just
kind of crumbled
at once but i i like what you're saying
i like what you're saying about the
issues idea
and that's how we can win because we
can't win on
breaking the people that are that this
is the danger of calling everyone a
racist it's so hard to break out of that
if you've
accused someone of being the scum of the
earth for for years
absolutely and and not only that i mean
a lot of people aren't going to want to
listen to like the sjw types who spout
this constantly anyway
i mean if you you can go to any any
online uh newspaper
and look at the comments on these sjw
articles people are just
angry people are pushing back they have
been for a while and
they should have seen it coming they
should have seen the popular discontent
and i again i i hate this kind of
collective guilt individual
responsibility
uh dichotomy they want to perform well
you know we
just just because we said this it
doesn't mean that you know ex it's like
no you're all saying this you're all
doing you have to understand that
the public if if you want us talking
groups and generalizations then the
public
is seeing this wall of hate coming from
the left-wing media and the left-wing
media is is populous it's
arrogant it's everywhere and for some
reason people still giving
keep giving credence especially with
their op-eds i just can't understand why
anyone reads them
but for some reason they do um so yeah
basically these people
they have to be i mean literally
everyone when they talk to them i have
to know you you lost
you're wrong you know i and i'm like
yeah but i've got all these all these
fancy justifications well it doesn't
matter
even if i don't know how they're wrong
well you failed i mean you you can't
appeal to voters with it therefore you
can never win the power back
therefore you can never in you know get
any of these things done therefore
you've lost it doesn't matter it doesn't
even matter what you're saying even if
what you're saying was brilliant and
it's not
it's [ __ ] but even if what you're
saying is brilliant
it doesn't matter it just doesn't work
it's like communism it's just not gonna
work it's a great philosophy but it's
never gonna work for human beings
and so this is the same thing it's it
it's just not possible so i i want them
to understand they have to change
and if they're not prepared to change
then they can't be part of the
conversation
i'm sorry to say it but you you are a
these people are a drag they hold the
left i mean they are the reason
the rest the left has lost so yeah we
definitely transition
from identity politics to issue politics
and
we need to understand why we care about
these things why
go back to the the root principles of
liberalism what it was designed for
and why and the just the the five sort
of principles that are the pillars of
western civilization were there for a
reason
you know that people look up to those
things for a reason i mean
and i i don't want to sound like a
western chauvinist but i am
there isn't a better system and if you
can pretty good it's pretty good the
west
exactly exactly it's the thing right no
oh if donald trump if donald trump wins
i'm going to move to canada no move to
mexico
you know shut up and mr next oh you
don't want to why is that
you know don't even move to saudi arabia
don't move to canada
that's full of white people you don't
want to go there by the way
lena dunham did not move for the rest no
of course they didn't know them did
they're full of [ __ ]
i can't understand why anyone listens to
celebrities on anything i mean in
ancient rome
actors and musicians were considered
lower
about the same social level as
prostitutes for what they could add to
society
and so i i really i think we maybe
should go back to that kind of
mindset again when george clooney says
oh we need to take loads of refugees
which go okay george
how many are you taking you know that's
very noble of you
but these people obviously don't need
live anywhere near any of the things
that are going on they don't care
they're not interested
they just want to virtue signal and feel
good about themselves and i'm sick of it
and i'm sure a lot of other people are
sick of it
and yeah suck it i don't care i was on a
i was on a radio show a progressive
radio show maybe eight months or so ago
and
the guy was being incredibly hostile to
me even though it was an old friend of
mine actually he was being really
hostile to me and i i was not being
hostile
and he we started talking about
immigration and i said look
i don't know what our vetting is it's
impossible to know what's going on it's
clear
look what's happening at the borders in
in europe like
we have to figure out what's going on
here and he kept trying to imply that i
was somehow being bigoted or racist or
something like that
and then i said to him i was like you
know uh if you're so for
immigration you make a lot more money
than me i know roughly how much you make
and you work at a big media company why
don't you uh
you know maybe take in a couple uh
immigrants take a couple migrants into
your house
and then suddenly he he freaked out well
that's not really over
and it's like no if you show these
people that this is not just theory you
can't just have your [ __ ] in theory you
have to have it in practice too
they crumble pretty quick absolutely
they they
they're never i mean one of the reasons
that um
the the people in the u are getting to
the point where they understand
is a the the way the votes and the polls
have been going recently
but um an eu official's daughter was
murdered by a migrant the other day
and it's just okay well now you know how
everyone else is feeling you know
like all of you i'll find a map and i'll
send it to you after this where the
it is basically um on google a live map
of just
all of the crimes that have been done by
migrants in germany and it's
it's just it's the whole country and
it's
thick with just you know you've got the
thing it's just
constant dots everywhere and it's like
my god i mean the the german
figures released from the german police
in 2016 uh was it 26th and 2015 i think
was actually uh
400 000 crimes were committed by these
migrants
it's i mean you know most of them are
petty crimes
but thefts and muggings and stuff like
that so it's not like life ending
but there are still thousands of people
who have been raped who have been
murdered and it's just
it's just like you didn't vet these
people at all you don't know who they
are
you don't know why they've come and i've
had people from syria commenting on my
videos going i know people have gone
there they've just gone for the money
they've just gone because they know that
the germans
will put them in a refugee camp and give
them money each month
and then as soon as they stop giving
money they leave i mean like when they
the the danish government said that they
weren't going to give benefits to
migrants only 4 000 of them left
oh really okay well there we go it's not
there was a war it's that you thought
you
needed some free money and and the thing
is it drives me crazy the whole sort of
i mean what did you think was gonna
happen you know you said oh yeah yeah
you can all come
we've got micro i mean obviously that's
going to incentivize people who aren't
actually there for the real reason
you know it's obviously going to do that
and then i've heard like plans of oh
what we're going to do is we're going to
pay them to go home it's like no
no that's [ __ ] we know that doesn't
work because of the vikings that's
exactly what the french and english
kings did and what happened oh more
vikings came
because they went back with a ton of
treasure and gone yeah this gave it to
us
you know it just it just incentivizes
people to you know to come
you unfortunately just you're gonna have
to do effectively what eastern europe is
doing just saying
no you know the answer is no go away you
know go to china ask them
you know go to iran ask them oh they're
gonna say no as well well there we go
you know it's i don't wanna sound
heartless but there are so many problems
that have come along with this and it's
been so
nobody apart from the political elite
have had any
input in any of this they haven't yet
merkel has been under such pressure not
to do this and yet she did it anyway
almost like an article of faith you know
when when you see her talk about she
would be talking about it almost as if
this was some kind of religious duty
that she was doing
and it's like okay that's dangerous you
know right and she
she did her religious duty and and what
happened a million and a half people
came in the system is under strain the
crime that you just mentioned
and then as of the time that we're
taping this today she's proposing this
burqa ban so it's like
this is a lot of room to help road to
hell yeah
i really trust you to get that sword
merkel yeah yeah yeah i trust that
you're going to be the one to do all
this
yeah you know forgive me if i'm cynical
here but
it's not i mean ultimately this migraine
crisis might be the result of
might end up with the eu breaking up
which in my opinion is a good thing but
i mean
surely they're not all looking at that
going on that's a great thing themselves
they must be furious
but um but yeah begin getting back to
the the reform of the left side i really
think this
is the most important thing for
left-leaning people to talk about
it's to understand how social justice
works
why it thinks what it thinks and then to
identify the people who are pushing it
and tell them
they have to change or they have to
leave because they do
they absolutely do um there there just
cannot be any room for this kind of
bigotry and that's what it is
you know to say well it's because you're
white that
that is a generalization based on race
that is the thing you complain about
when it happens to black people i don't
care what your
systems of oppression say on an
individual level that's an
unacceptable thing to do even if you
think it's justified
and they do and that's why like your
friend like you're saying he was get he
was being really hostile to you
when you were being polite there's no
excuse for that but they think they're
acting in service of a greater good
and and that's one thing that i think
there are so many just like elementary
concepts
that these people forgot i mean the
greater good or the common good well the
common good
is for everyone the greater good is for
a certain section of people
and almost i mean i can't think of an
ideology in the 20th century that didn't
butcher people
that didn't also have a greater good in
mind
when they were butchering people and
then fidel castro dies and you see
trudeau
like oh oh my hero dude
he had firing squads just execution
squads this guy was a monster
i can't believe it you know yeah
everything's kind of backwards you know
it all sort of leads me to i think where
we should probably
uh end this for today although next time
we're going to get you in the states
finally
we're going to do this live but um
that for people with flexible minds
because i think that's the through line
here
is that as a classical liberal as what a
liberal
is supposed to be uh i think we have
flexible minds i'm pretty sure that
there's no information if i could prove
to you was true
that you would you might not like it at
first you might try to argue against it
but if i consistently prove something to
be true
uh that you would eventually come around
and that's what a flexible mind is all
about not being beholden to an ideology
but being rational
but being rational being beholden to the
truth and we seem to live in a time that
everyone's using this phrase post-truth
now where everyone just kind of makes up
their own
truth but we live in a time where it's
like the loudest people are screaming
and the loudest people are getting the
most retweets and the most views
and all the click bait and all that
stuff where it's for people like us and
i think for the people that
like that are watching this right now
that like the stuff that we're doing and
we're putting out there
it makes our job a little harder because
having a flexible mind also
means i think i want to live a pretty
decent life
too i want to not devote every bit of
energy that i have to
to fighting with people and all that
stuff and and not being not becoming a
demagogue that i would hate at the same
time and there
so basically basically i just view this
as our job is a little harder
because being rational in an irrational
world is a little harder
i i think that our job is made more
difficult than
everyone else's job by the fact that we
don't have an identity
that's the problem and i mean like
but you've been arguing against identity
politics the whole time i know i have
i know i know i don't i'm not suggesting
that identity is
a panacea for anything but there's
the alts right became a really powerful
force but if you look at it
the ark right is tiny the old world's
really small i mean they're
like the biggest alt-right bloggers have
got like 30 40
000 subscribers you know that's a tiny
movement
and yet they were just dedicated and
noisy online they caused a lot of
trouble
and suddenly hillary clinton is
legitimizing them in a speech it's like
oh my god
that's that's [ __ ] posting has gone from
the internet to hillary clinton's mouth
where she's denouncing a cartoon frog
she's literally
reading milo's breitbart articles
and by the way milo isn't even
considered alt-right enough for the true
all right
you of course he's not partnered all
right
he just likes them because they're fun
yeah you know you've got to handle them
the memes are funny
well that's the irony everything has
been flipped on its head right now
there's such
self-righteous drivel coming out of the
left right now that nothing's funny the
daily show is not
funny oh the the what's her name that
has that tbs show i keep watching these
commercials
it's like it's not funny you're all
lecturers and actually the stuff that is
funny
i don't like i don't like the swastika i
don't i don't like
nazis but the stuff that's coming out of
the right
is actually the subversive stuff now
comedy is supposed to be subversive it's
supposed to be against the power
and the left is just sucking up to the
machine absolutely
the left have been pontificating for
years they they
like it's exactly the same nina the
daily show and uh was it samantha b
oh that's the one i was thinking of i
mean it's appallingly horrible
it's just not funny you're not funny at
all so stop please guys you know
um but yeah but that's the thing they've
got they've got a narrative they want to
project and
they can't mock their own narrative you
know and they're the ones trying to set
like a normative no this is how it
should be
and it's like well no it shouldn't it's
nonsense and these guys are just mocking
you relentlessly
i mean with the thing with the facts
that's i i totally agree there isn't
that there there should be no facts that
are forbidden and that's
again i mean that is probably one of the
key crutches of the left for example
like
that there is no denying that black
people
on average have a lower distribution of
iq
than some other race like white people
and asians right there's no doubting
that but what drives me
i mean that scientific fact but what
drives me crazy about the old right
is when they go right so now we can do
something except then we can't
no we can't we don't penalize people for
having a low iq at all
and you're not trying to do anything
about the white people with low iq
so that just means you're targeting
black people because they're black
you don't care about the iq at all
that's just a convenient foil
we're not going to do anything to any of
these people based on their iq we don't
do that
we're not going to start now stop asking
it's not going to happen
you know this is some ridiculous it's
like sjw saying right okay we'll have
everyone at the same level at some point
no that's not going to happen either
you both got this utopian ridiculous
idea and but
what's worse is it it's going to
necessitate totalitarianism
to make sure everyone marches in
lockstep with what you want done
you're going to have to become
totalitarians and i'm really
comfortable with the free open and
liberal society so the answer is no
to both of them you know they they they
can both go hang as far as i'm concerned
um but the left just needs to learn how
to be funny again frankly
maybe it can do that now that it's uh
kind of lost all the power and failed
completely
but i mean that that could be the saving
grace that suddenly they're gonna have
to fight the power again and maybe that
will actually lead
liberalism to go back to its liberal
roots
uh listen carl i i could do easily
another hour with you but
i gotta run we got a ton to do to get
this thing in order for next week
but it was a pleasure talking to you as
always and uh
you know look some of these ideas are
getting out there that that's the
beautiful thing and we just gotta keep
pressing and yeah our job may be harder
but
if not us you know who else is going to
do it well that's the thing isn't it you
know if
if not us then who if not now then when
but um okay so
i'll leave you look with the last things
that the the people who are
sort of rational liberals they need an
identity they
need some sort like the alt right has
like like intersex and social justice
advocates have
you know they that you need some kind of
unifying identity and it's not for
yourselves that you need this
it's for other people that you need this
is so the media can say oh well like you
know these these like new liberals are
doing something
you know or you know the the the
alt-right uh attacking the new liberals
or something like this
is to get a sort of political map in
people's minds and stake out your place
in that map and so people can recognize
you as a force
that needs to be dealt with because i
mean between us we're coming on a
million subscribers
and yet i don't feel like we're getting
anything done and i think it's because
people don't have a mental map of us
they don't really know where to place us
they're just kind of they're just seeing
individuals with
large audiences and thinking well it's
just one guy you know okay he's got a
big reach but
you know i'll just ignore him block him
or something and then he's gone but if
if we can find a label that we're all
generally happy to use that we can push
and like you coordinate on hashtags and
things like that then we could actually
start seeing
us breaking into the mainstream just
like the alt-right that's exactly how
the alt-right did it
that's exactly honestly is probably have
feminists did it to be honest i i
should go and check the history but it's
it's having a name and
one thing sorry a very quick last thing
everyone always gets
everyone always gets hung up on the idea
of community and the sort of purity of
the community um drop it just drop it
just drop
i mean communities are just something
people do that's
a group people hanging out together is a
community it's no big deal to call
something a community
and okay well i'm happy to not have
collective blame
as long as we don't need collective
guilt and responsibility so
that's fine if someone in the community
is bad then we'll say okay that person
was a problem we're sorry you know we
we've disavowed him don't worry about it
now we're all you know it it's not a big
deal it's
people people act like you're signing up
to an organization you're getting a card
and you you know now now you've got a
whole list of rules to follow no
it's just do what the alt-right did do
what the feminist did
do what every social movement's doing
online find an identity and
push it and so you can at least and we
can all at least agree on like four or
five basic principles like you know
secularism skepticism individual rights
uh freedom of expression and what
democracy or you know it's not like
the these sort of five points who's
who's in disagreement with that you know
there are going to be millions of people
and this is what drives me crazy because
if we had
some kind of identity we could probably
activate
millions of people if we could get on
you know get on tv and be like no this
is what we are
this is what you stand for because
you've failed and you're horrible so
you know this is what we want i think we
would get a huge flood of people coming
to us
because i think most people are on our
side well you know what i started this
by saying that i don't know that we can
win but i think you just did a beautiful
two-minute job of what our
work should be for 2017 so uh i'm gonna
keep working
oh that's all i did all right brother
well
it was a pleasure talking to you and
yeah i mean this is it this is it and i
know that people
people hear you they hear me they hear
the other this other gang of amorphous
people that are coming together
and i think that that the next the next
wave of this
is in our favor and we're going to keep
pushing so we'll do it again soon man
you